hey this is presh talwalkar and you're
watching mind your decisions
here's a fun problem involving an
infinite number of square roots
what is the value of 10 times the square
root of everything that's inside times
10 times the square root of everything
that's inside times 10 times the square
root of everything that's inside times
10 times the square root of everything
that's inside repeated infinitely many
times
if you can solve this problem you can
then consider the variation where
instead of 10 we have an alternation of
3 and 5.
another variation is to consider we have
10 under each radical but instead of
just having a square root we have an nth
root
this will be for n is equal to whole
number of values like 2 3 4 5 and so on
finally what would happen instead of one
fixed value of this root we have an
increasing value so we have 10 times the
square root of everything that's inside
times 10 times the cube root of
everything that's inside times 10 times
the fourth root of everything that's
inside times 10 times the fifth root of
everything that's inside and so on
repeated infinitely many times
i think abdel hakeem from algeria for
suggesting this in fact the problem with
alternating three and five terms
appeared on a math competition for third
year students in high school which would
be about 16 and 17 year olds
can you figure these out
give them a try and when you're ready
keep watching the video for a solution
now before i get to the answer it's very
important that a youtube channel of my
size and reach mentions something about
convergence of an infinite product
the infinite product of positive real
numbers converges if and only if the
following infinite sum converges
in other words if we take the term by
term natural logarithm and we add up all
of those terms and that is a convergent
series then we know that the infinite
product also converges
so this gives a connection between
the convergence of an infinite product
and the convergence of infinite sums and
most of us have studied infinite sum
convergence in class so we can apply the
basic lessons
now in this video we're going to be
dealing with things which are infinite
sums that we're very familiar with like
geometric series
so there's no need to formally check the
exact convergence you're going to see
why they converge through the derivation
but if you really wanted to check the
details you can go ahead and check using
this formal method
so now let's get to the answers
how do we solve this problem
well we'll solve it by considering the
partial products
the first partial product will be 10 or
10 to the power of 1.
the next term will be 10 times the
square root of the previous term so we
have ten to the power of one times ten
to the power of one half
or ten to the power of one plus one half
the next term is ten times the square
root of the previous term
so we get ten to the power of one plus
one half plus one fourth
and this pattern continues
where the nth term is equal to 10 times
the square root of the previous term
and when you work it out we end up with
the following pattern we have 10 to a
geometric series we have 1 plus 1
one-half plus one-fourth plus so on plus
one to the power of two to the n
so now how can we figure out the value
well the exponent is a convergent
geometric series and we can use the
formula for the sum of the geometric
series to get that the exponent will be
equal to 2.
so all of this is equal to 10 squared or
100
and that's it
so now it's a little more complicated if
you have alternating terms of 3 and 5.
let's consider the partial products
the first partial product will be 3
times the square root of 5 which is
equal to 3 to the power of 1 times 5 to
the power of 1 half
the next partial product will take 3
times the square root of everything
that's inside times five times the
square root of the previous term
and when you work that out you end up
getting
three to the power of one plus one
fourth multiplied by five to the power
of one half plus one eighth
now we can continue this pattern where
the nth term is equal to 3 times the
square root of everything that's inside
of 5 times the square root of the
previous term
and when you work it out we end up with
3 going to the power of 1 plus 1 4 and
all these powers of 4 until we get 1
over 4 to the power of n and we need to
multiply all of this
by 5 raised to the other powers
we have one half plus 1 8 and so on
where we get 1 over 2 times 4 to the n
so now how do we solve for this value
well we have a 2 convergent geometric
series and we can solve for their values
so we end up with three to the power of
four thirds multiplied by five to the
power of two thirds
now let's consider if we have the nth
root
well this is very much like the square
root problem the first term will be
equal to 10 to the power of 1
then each subsequent term will equal 10
times the nth root of the previous term
and we can go ahead and solve for the
pattern here and we end up with the
geometric series
where the common ratio is 1 over n
so now we can solve for the value of
this infinite nested product by solving
for the sum of this geometric series
and then we get the answer of 10 to the
power of n all over n minus 1.
and notice if you substitute in n is
equal to 2 you get 10 squared and that
exactly matches what we solved in the
very first problem
now what would happen if we have an
increasing nth root
this is a little bit trickier to solve
but let's work it out
the first term is equal to 10 to the
power of 1
the next partial product will be 10
times the square root of 10 so we get 10
to the power of 1 plus 1 half
the third partial term will be the
second term and then we have the square
root of the cube root of 10
and this works out to be 10 to the power
1 plus 1 over 2 plus 1 over 2 times 3.
and when you work out this pattern you
end up that the next term or the k term
is equal to the previous term multiplied
by this following nested radical we have
the second root the third earth and all
the way to the kth root of 10. and when
you work that out it ends up being the
sum of factorials like this 10 to the
power of 1 plus 1 over 2 factorial plus
1 over 3 factorial and so on to 1 over k
factorial
so now we look at this exponent
and this is another familiar pattern
this is equal to e minus one because e
is equal to exactly this infinite series
plus one
so this all will be the value of ten to
the power of e minus one
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video these
math videos which can be watched for
free on youtube inspire and build
confidence for people around the world
and they already have over a hundred
million views please subscribe for free
to get the newest videos and email me a
puzzle or math topic presh
mindyourdecisions.com if you so choose
to support this channel you can get some
merchandise at teespring you can check
out my books which are listed in the
video description and you can support me
on patreon for exclusive rewards
thanks for watching and thanks for your
support